ROLL ON is back, we're hitting our zone two stride.
Yessiree.
Adam should we do this show?
I think so, there's so much to discuss this...
It's not a week, it's like a...
It's not a two weeks it's been, is it third?
Is it a...
What's a three week?
Is it an epoch?
Is an epoch three weeks?
Let's just stop with the distractions.
Let's just fucking do the show.
(logo whooshing)
(country music)
♪ Born in 1966 ♪
♪ He turned his life around. ♪
♪ He wasn't doing so hot. ♪
♪ Rich Roll. ♪
♪ He got rid of that weight and he gained a lot of wisdom. ♪
♪ He lives in a tent. ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
♪ Thank you all so much for playing along. ♪
♪ And I hope you have a wonderful night ♪
♪ and I'd like to welcome to the stage ♪
♪ Mr. Rich Roll ♪
(logo whooshing)
Hey, everybody, welcome to ROLL ON.
We're the grounded good natured,
but sometimes cantankerous journalist and author
Adam Skolnick and I clip matters of interest
from the internet and real life.
We opine on sports, culture, entertainment, self betterment,
and occasionally sometimes against my better instincts
politics.
We answer our listener question here and there
and so much more.
So today we got plenty of news from the front lines of
endurance, including we hope at this point,
a very special and exclusive call with the newly crowned
Ironman World Champion Kristian Blummenfelt
and his coach Olav Aleksander Bu.
We may or may not get a little bit political today.
We answer a listener question and we're gonna close with
another coaching call check in with a friend of the podcast,
personal friend, Chris Hauth.
But first how goes it my comrade?
Rich I'm perplexed.
Hmm.
You're into wellness, right?
Would you describe yourself as a wellness guy?
I don't like labels.
Okay.
Adam.
But the reason I bring it up--
I'm into wellness, yes.
You're into wellness.
I think you're the guy--
I'm a wellness influencer.
(both laughing)
You're a well-influencer.
(Rich laughing)
I think you're the guy...
Actually I think I've got a new podcast episode for you,
but it's all about the movable itch,
you know like what is it about the...
That sounds like a book title.
Right?
But like what is it about the human body
where you haven't an itch on your back,
someone scratches it for you and then it moves
just so slightly up or down, sometimes to the side
and then you have to tell them to move
and then they scratch it and you say, "Harder"
and then it moves again.
It leaps frogs around,
how come we've never figured out why that happens.
I don't know. We should get Andrew Huberman in here.
That's what I'm thinking.
This is a Huberman pod waiting to happen.
He's got a guy, you know he's got a guy at Stanford--
I'm sure he has an answer for this.
He's got a guy at Stanford looking at this.
What's interesting to me is like
I don't walk around itching and scratching myself.
But when I go to bed at night and I'm lying in bed
and right before I'm about to fall asleep,
suddenly I'll have like an unbearable itch
that I have to scratch--
(Adam laughing)
And always right in the middle.
And then it's somewhere else after that.
And I'm like, I didn't have to do this 10 minutes ago.
It's my point.
Right?
It's a human problem.
This is one for the ages
we must get to the bottom of this.
I think we gotta do a full pod
just on the moveable itch.
Okay, how about a whole series.
Whole series on it.
A six part limited series.
Yes, yes.
For Netflix.
A Netflix doco.
(Adam laughing)
Okay.
Why?
All right, well I know you love sharks.
I do.
We have some shark news.
Yeah, yeah, I've got a couple of stories out
this last week.
One came out Thursday...
We're recording this on a Monday, came out last Thursday
for outside, but it'll be wide.
It'll be available wide for all comers the same day
this pod drops.
So that's good news.
It's based on a reporting trip I did to La Paz
in Southern Baja,
and it's all about a marine biologist
and her pals who started a foundation,
nonprofit down in Southern Baja to get the shark fishermen
who live there to start to see sharks,
to get them to see that they're worth more
alive than dead basically.
And so there's 80 plus shark fishing villages and camps
in Southern Baja.
There has been four or five generations,
they used to use kind of used to be like...
They're all artisanal fishermen.
They just use a line in a hook.
They're not going out there with nets
and they've been doing it for generations.
They've been sending shark fins to Hong Kong since the '30s.
It was never a big problem until
the outboard motors came along and competition
became more fierce and now they have to go miles offshore,
used to be sharks, they can get 'em in the bay.
Now they have to go miles and miles offshore.
They get paid very little because
the shark numbers are down so much.
I think worldwide it's 70% of sharks have been killed,
basically that were once here.
That's the number I could come across.
And so because of that, the sharks are smaller.
The fins are smaller.
They're earning about $150 a week doing this kind of job.
And it's dangerous.
They're going miles offshore and little pangas and--
To be clear.
Yeah.
They're fishing for sharks to cut their fins off
and sell them.
Yep.
Right.
And they're not really able to make a living doing this.
So can we not transition them into some other
type of career.
That's what it's all about.
Yeah, that's the whole point of the story.
(Adam laughing)
Thanks.
So here's a problem.
Like if you look up on the that's screen there.
I have the article pulled up on outside.
But then I come here and it says,
"Become a member, unlock this and get other great perks."
And I'm like, I don't know that I tried to log in.
I don't think that...
I have so many subscriptions.
I know.
And it's like--
I'm trying to sell you another one.
I know.
So I actually didn't read your article.
(Adam laughing)
That's the story.
Even though I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you, thanks for bringing it in, okay.
And you know, you'd think, I don't know...
Well, I mean, look
I was on the cover of this magazine humble brag.
Oh.
So can't they
spot me a subscription.
You know, I've writing for them--
I think I actually do have a subscription.
I just don't know what my login credentials are.
I bought my subscription because even though I've been
writing for them for years and years, I've they've...
you know, that's so funny.
I would think that as a contributor to any publication,
I should just get a free subscription, its never happened.
You should
Never happened.
No one's ever offered me.
Have you asked though?
No.
That should be a perk.
I'm non-confrontational.
I don't wanna have that conversation.
It might be beneficial to actually be able to read the
publication that you're contributing to.
It should be a perk.
It should be like automatically you contribute,
like maybe not once,
but if you contribute two or three times,
they should just be feeding it to you.
Even the New York Times?
No, I pay for that.
You do?
Yeah.
I've never asked, maybe I'm gonna start asking.
I think you should ask, stand up for yourself.
Thank you.
Adam Skolnick.
I will.
But that's exactly what the story is about.
It's about the efforts to get people to stop shark fishing,
but the real problem there isn't just the fact
that they're fishing for sharks and it's
endangering the shark populations.
It's that there are mainland Mexico,
industrial fishing operations that come to Southern Baja and
take up these huge drift nets and go in one go, in one day,
they can take more tuna than these guys, fish for bait,
when they use tuna for bait for these sharks
they get more in one day than these shark fishermen
can get in a year.
And that's what's destroying the economy and the ecology.
And so there is a group of people led by these marine
biologists in La Paz that is trying to get the entirety
of Southern Baja as one MPA that allows for fishing,
allows for sport fishing, spear fishing,
and artisanal fishing.
And so they don't wanna take the livelihood away,
but it cuts off industrial fishing forever.
And that can really do good.
So the point is to try to get these guys boats
that are fit for tourists, to get them tourists to come,
to train them, to be able to take tourists out
to look at the amazing wildlife.
I mean, Southern Baja, especially around La Paz
has some of the most amazing wildlife in the world.
It's like the confluence of equatorial currents
and Alaskan currents that come down
from Northern California,
from Alaska all the way down past California to Mexico,
that confluence means it's like a haven for several species
of whale, several species of sharks, whale sharks,
sea lions, you name it.
Right.
And so it's an incredible place to go.
Obviously under threat by the industrial fishing industry.
That's right.
And the problem is that industrial fishing businesses
and their people who represent them have
convinced sport fishermen and artisanal fishermen,
that MPAs are bad for them.
When in reality,
the opposite has been proven to be true.
So the point here,
and MPAs aren't even bad for industrial fishermen.
It just means they have to pause in certain areas.
But if you look at it,
guess where a lot of the fishing fleet
is near the Galapagos?
They're right at the edge of the Galapagos National Park.
Well, why is that?
Because the Galapagos National Park
produces such biodiversity that it doesn't support at all.
People have...
The animals have to move.
And so when they move out, you know
you're basically feeding the rest of the ocean--
Right, right, right.
with wildlife.
So that's why MPAs are great.
So this gets into a little bit of all of that.
Right?
And then you followed that up with another article.
Yeah, story came out today.
I wrote it actually a little while ago,
but they posted it today.
It's about a free diver, 105 meter free immersion,
free diver named Denis Grosmaire.
He lives in Tikehau in the Tuamotu in French Polynesia.
And I met him out there and just stayed in touch with him.
He is amazing because in his spare time,
when he is not leading tourists around on you know,
manta dives and training to be a great free diver,
he literally goes out there and does the "Octopus Teacher"
thing with 14 foot tiger sharks.
Right.
(both laughing)
So the New York Times article online.
Yeah.
Opens with this incredible video of him just out there,
messing around with these tiger sharks.
We're watching, you know, a gigantic one swim right past him
right now.
As he sort of pets it?
Yeah, he pets them, he hugs them.
He tries to kiss them.
Doesn't always go well.
Well, there's one story in the article about where yeah,
he leaned down to kiss the shark and realized
his head was inside its mouth.
Yes, I saw that footage.
And he narrowly escaped.
Yeah, I saw that footage.
Being decapitated by his buddy.
That's right, lover.
Cause he names all he names all the sharks, right?
Yes.
And he knows them.
He identifies them.
He knows their personalities.
He's a real wild man, he loved "Octopus Teacher"
so like that is basically a great...
I tried to put that reference into the story.
It got cut out by three different editors.
So I just guess it wasn't a good one, so I--
I'll check that out, that's in print today, right?
Yeah, and what's interesting about Denis Grosmaire
is he is the product of a single mom grew up
in remote French Polynesia.
His older brother, Jody Grosmaire was a world champion,
Brazilian jujitsu fighter.
And his younger brother is Tikanui Smith,
who is one of the great surfers at Chopo--
Oh wow, wow.
in Tahiti, so yeah.
So like just a lineage of water people, cool.
What a family, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
That's cool, how do you find these people in these stories?
You know, I happened to be out in Tahiti
and in French Polynesia, I went to Tikehau
and I heard about him out there and I got introduced to him.
And so basically he took me out on his boat,
took April and I out and we cruised around, and swam with
mantas, and saw where he lived and just hung out.
Did some spear fishing,
saw a big shark come by when he caught a fish.
And that looked like...
so that's the biggest angriest shark
I've ever been that close to,
it was a silver tip shark.
And I'd never seen, I didn't know...
It looked like an oceanic white tip to me.
It was a big burly shark and its fins were down
and it was hunting,
and he had just speared a fish and had
to pull it outta the water.
And then it went down, and then he puts the fish on the boat
and then he hands me the spear and he goes,
"Okay, it's your turn."
And then I look down, there's this silver
giant angry shark is like right below me. I'm like, really?
So what does that mean when it's fins are down?
That's an indication that it's hunting.
It looked like it, you know, like it looked like,
you know, the body language or the shark looked like
it was hungry.
(Adam laughing)
Mm, and you're tasty.
Right, but usually sharks don't look like that.
It look like this, although it's fins are down,
but it looks very calm.
Right, you can tell.
Nice man, cool.
What else are you working on?
That's it, you know, we're in book world as well,
but that's all I can report on now.
Rich, how are you?
How are you?
I was just waiting for you to ask.
You know, I'm not really listening to you.
I'm just waiting until it's my turn to talk, Adam.
How are you?
I'm good, we had a nice mother's day.
Yes.
Yesterday with the kids, which was great.
The main thing with me is my back is not doing very well.
So about four or five days ago,
it just really seized up on me.
So I've been in rather excruciating pain that I believe must
be exacerbated by the uptick in the swim training
that I've been doing.
Yeah.
So much so that, like, I can't sit up in bed
or when I sit in a chair,
you'll see when we're done with this podcast,
when I go to stand up, it's like, I can't stand up straight.
It's really painful.
And I'm in the middle of undergoing
this pretty advanced high tech therapy that involve...
Did I talk about this last time?
No.
So I went up to the bay area a couple weeks ago to visit
this clinic where I was injected with
PRP replacement therapy.
Okay.
Peptides, and also this derivative from placenta,
it's kind of like a stem cell analog.
Yeah.
And over the course of a four hour period,
got dozens of injections in my back,
which I was told would not be painful,
but turned out to be excruciatingly painful--
Did Samuel Alito authorize that use of placenta?
No, we're gonna get to that.
Okay.
Yeah, not yet soon--
(Adam laughing)
Don't tell, 'em.
I would imagine.
Do not tell 'em.
Yes liberty.
It was actually very painful because my muscles
are so jacked up back there.
Right.
And it's a long process
I've been told that it could take up to six months.
They're relatively optimistic about their ability to kind of
help me out.
Essentially I have Spondy and my L four protrudes
about a centimeter towards my abdomen.
So it's out of whack and it's pinching these nerves
and it's just causing all kinds of pain--
And that's called Spondy pain.
Spondylothesis
Okay.
I think is how you say it.
And what does the placenta cells do?
What do they do?
Well, they're...
As I understand it, and you know,
I probably should have researched this a little bit more to
speak more, you know, informed about it,
but essentially it's a solution of,
sort of like stem cells where they can kind of go repair
certain areas and become whatever is needed
in order to like, you know, basically solve the problem.
So it's basically this solution of these different things
that my lower back is now being bathed in
that over time will help regenerate the kind of fluid around
the L four and create a bit more space that relaxes
the muscles.
And that will in time allow that L four to kind of go back
in place where it's meant to.
Okay.
But in the meantime, I'm in a lot of pain and
I'm probably in jeopardy of being able to do this
20 kilometer swim race,
because I had a big block over the weekend that I was
supposed to execute on, but I just I, you know, I can't.
I can barely move right now.
Oh man.
Which is just not fun.
You look great, that's a great looking cardigan.
Thanks.
I wish I could be in the pool though.
I know,
You know,
and I think it has to do with the turns and the flip turns.
Right.
It's not necessarily the swimming 'cause
I've been swimming a lot and not running
for the sole purpose of not doing anything that is
creating that kind of jarring impact.
But I think pushing off the walls and you know,
when you flip and you arch your back that way, I could tell
like I was starting to get a lot of strain doing that.
And I think that really exacerbated the situation.
Ooh, you gotta ping.
I gotta ping.
But basically Olav just pinged you.
Yes.
They're in the Denver airport.
They're gonna grab something to eat and then make themselves
available to check in,
which is a good segue into kind of what we wanted to talk
about next in our typical endurance sports
check in corner of the show,
which is that this past Saturday was Ironman St. George.
Yes.
Which happened to be the 2021 World Championships--
Ironman,
which is hilarious because we're halfway to 2022.
It is hilarious, it is funny.
A result of them canceling Kona during the pandemic.
They're still gonna be the 2022 World Championships in
Kona in October, right.
Right, that's right.
So this is like the delayed World Championship
from the previous year.
It's like the Oscars except the World Championship race.
I guess, right.
Yeah, Yeah.
So you wanna just set the stage--
Yeah
for what went down here.
So basically it was meant to be kind of the,
I guess, put up or shut up time for the Norwegians, right.
Who've been throwing down incredible times at races.
Kristian won the Tokyo gold.
Then he had the fastest ever full distance Ironman
triathlon in Cozumel.
Gustav won a race as well at a really, really fast time.
Gustav Iden.
And so it's supposed to be their time.
Are they gonna be who everyone says they are or not?
I think there was the smack talk from Alistair Brownlee
saying, you know, do you believe the hype train
or don't believe--
No, I don't think that was Brownlee.
It was that other British guy who ended up dropping out.
So yeah, lot of these guys ended up not competing.
So it was meant to be this showdown between Blummenfelt,
Iden, Frodeno and possibly Brownlee,
but Frodeno, Iden and Brownlee were all out.
Yeah, but Frodeno, you know, that was a really...
but it didn't surprise me 'cause he loves Kona so much.
So maybe he's like putting everything on Kona.
Maybe.
Yeah.
So going into this race, it looked like
it was gonna be a showdown between Blummenfelt,
Lionel Sanders and Cameron Wurf.
Yep.
And Blummenfelt just crushed it.
He got outta the water, I don't know,
like four minutes back or something like that
found himself in no man's land on the bike
a bit behind the lead pack,
but ahead of the second pack and he just kind of waited for
Cameron Wurf to catch up to him
and paced himself off of Cameron got off the bike
and then just killed the run.
Mm.
Just crushing--
I mean he was what?
Was he like four minutes back on the bike,
four and a half minutes,
4:46 behind something like that,
finished almost five minutes clear.
Did his, I think he did a 2:38, marathon.
Right, so he just worked his way through the pack.
I don't think he took the lead until like mile 18.
That's right.
And he averaged 602 miles running.
602 per mile.
520 miles around mile 20.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the amazing thing about all of this
is that he did it with a virus, like he was not a 100%.
No.
I mean, his coach said he was 90%.
Gustav couldn't even start.
Right.
Yeah, they had the same thing and didn't Olav say that,
you know, if it hadn't been the World Championship--
Yes.
he wouldn't have started.
And he like vomited right before the race
and vomited afterwards.
He looked like he was vomiting right at the end, right.
When he got there, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Olav said that he would not have started him
if it wasn't the World Championship.
But then the fact that he rocked it so hard.
I mean, and it was...
I just love the way he finishes these races.
He shows so much emotion,
the same thing in Tokyo and just like,
he wants to be the best and it's fun to see an athlete
that admits that.
And then, you know, these guys called their shot.
Like Olav had said in the article I wrote about these guys
that it's gonna be like taking candy from a baby to win the
Ironman World Championship.
I mean, that's huge words for someone who at that point,
hadn't even done a full distance race yet.
Yeah.
And so to see that kind of, you know,
I guess you have to go back old timers,
Joe Namath and that kind of thing.
Like the Babe Ruth call your shot.
Like it just doesn't happen.
It's very rare that it happens.
Commentators do it,
but athletes tend not to do it
and coaches tend not to do it,
but they did it and they backed it up.
It's pretty amazing.
Right, when you say it out loud and then you back it up.
It's amazing.
It makes for a pretty great story.
And I think this is just the beginning.
Yeah, I think so too.
I mean it certainly setting up that way.
He's 26 years old, I believe.
And then Gustav is also right there
and we'll see what he's got.
I mean, shout out to Lionel Sanders for an amazing finish.
I mean just an incredible--
He's an animal.
He's an animal and it's crazy that he can run
as well as he does, 'cause he's got this wacky form.
Yeah, I love it, I love his form.
He's got an amazing backstory.
I've been trying to get him on the podcast forever.
'Cause his backstory is unbelievable.
And now he spends a lot of time training in Arizona,
but he's from Canada.
And traditionally he spends most of the year in his basement
where he has an infinity pool and a treadmill and his bike
on a trainer and he never leaves this tiny room.
And he does all of his training indoors in his basement,
Like in a small pool with like a treadmill thing.
Yeah you know like those little
pools where they have circular current or whatever.
So he has, it's literally like this setup.
That's just, you know, in this room--
In Tucson
No, no, in Canada.
In Canada, okay.
Where it's inclement most of the time
he can't ride outdoors.
So you know, when it's snowing outside,
he's just in this room for like nine hours a day training.
Crazy.
Now he does... I think he spends time in Palm Springs
and in Arizona he does lots of camps there.
Yeah.
So I don't know how much he's doing that now,
but there are these amazing videos that Talbot Cox made way
back in the day are like
a day in the life of Lionel Sanders.
And he's just in this room, you know,
just like, and he can suffer, you know,
he just pushes himself--
Clearly.
so hard.
Also shout out to Cameron Wurf,
this guy for people who don't know
is just an extraordinary athlete.
Yep.
He is a pro cyclist, a domestic for INEOS
and he's been living in Europe, riding races for this team.
And he just got back like from racing Paris-Roubaix
where he helped his team win.
He was the domestic supporting Dylan van Baarle
who took the win
and like left that and just goes right to St. George
to compete in the Ironman World Championships.
He's like, "I haven't swam at all."
Like he hasn't been focused on Ironman really at all.
And shout out to Cameron for being a semi-Calabasas native.
He spends a of time out here training.
He was out here training with Geraint Thomas,
who was the 2018 tour France winner.
So he's a bit of a temporary local out in these parts.
Nice.
And if you're out riding your bike,
you probably have seen him riding around out--
You gotta get 'em into the studio.
I'd love to have them on.
Yeah.
So Cameron, if you're listening next time,
swing through LA let's make that happen.
Shout out also...
Oh, well one last thing on Kristian,
he's the first to ever win the Olympic gold and the Ironman
title in a calendar year.
Right.
And so that's amazing only the second ever to have both,
but I think there was several years between Jan
winning the gold and then winning the Ironman.
So it doesn't usually happen that quickly happen for them.
Shout out to Daniela Ryf, her fifth world title.
She finished in 8 hours and 34 minutes,
third, most titles ever on the women's side,
she won by almost nine minutes.
Right, and in the women's race,
the big omission was Lucy Charles-Barclay
did not compete due to an injury.
So awesome.
So why don't we take a quick break and we'll be back with a
quick zoom check in with Kristian Blummenfeld and his coach.
Olav Aleksander Bu.
Live from the Denver airport.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us, as a writer and podcaster
for nearly 10 years.
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down the most
compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium by which to share
their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release of my new
book, "Voicing Change Volume II"
more than mere words on paper.
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the ritual podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change" was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table and
volume two follows in that tradition by showcasing even more
of my favorite conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday profits
and physically interact with the
life changing ideas contained with them.
"Voicing Change Volume II" available now while supplies last
for a limited time.
Order your copy today only @richroll.com.
All right.
Yeah.
There they are, the champion.
How we doing?
How are you guys doing thank you so much for taking time.
You're at the airport, you gotta layover.
And I appreciate you just taking a couple minutes and
finding a quiet space to talk to us.
So we won't take up too much of your time,
but we're happy to be able to congratulate you,
what an amazing performance
and we're anxious to kind of hear your thoughts
in the wake of making history in the triathlon world.
Well, yes, as well, thank you so much.
It was quite a tricky kind of preparation I would say,
like I did first one in like six months ago now
and I thought I would feel more prepared
coming into this one,
but I think we maybe did a little bit too much time up
in altitude.
So I didn't feel too fresh coming to St. George.
We like came like three weeks early to kind of just
nail the course and do the preparation there.
But then I managed to get a cold like first week.
So it was kind of feeling that I hadn't done everything I
could, like, I was kind of...
I wasn't sure how my fitness would be or how my body
would be responding.
But luckily I was able to do like one solid bike ride,
like went through the whole course the week before
felt all right, and the same on the run.
So that kind of gave me a confidence that on race day
I could be good and yeah, had a good day I would say,
especially on the bike and the run,
I was able to produce good power and was very strong
until the end, so happy with that.
Yeah, I think that's an understatement.
Well, Olav, you had said you went on record saying that,
you know Kristian was not well, he was fighting a virus.
Gustav had to drop out for having the same illness
and Kristian you like vomited before the race.
I mean, Olav you had said he was at 90%.
Sounds like he might have even been operating at less than
90% and still capable of, you know,
putting in the performance that we all witnessed.
Yeah, up in altitude there were actually several people
starting to get sick.
Some people we even heard got COVID.
So we were actually a little bit afraid that people had been
catching COVID or guys have got COVID,
but we did I'll say the testing and everything just to
ensure that that was not the case.
So we got confirmed that it was a cold,
so Gustav was the first one to...
Or he got it from somebody up there then...
But he eventually we dropped it.
I'll say, we reduced the training quite significantly
focused on getting him back as quickly as possible.
And then being able to nail in like one good preparatory
session, yeah.
That we had optimized from after our leading into Cozumel.
And then when we came to St. George of course,
we were really surprised by the dry conditions.
And of course this is challenging,
especially because it dries out the mucus membranes.
So you are less protected from viruses and bacteria.
Kristian, when we landed, got sick and actually got quite,
I would say got a quite severe cold.
So actually not only upper respiratory system,
but actually also the lower.
So in the lungs as well, coughing slime, and yeah,
it was pretty severe.
Yeah, same of course you can't do anything
and you just bring down and focus on getting as quickly as
possible fresh.
Went to the doctor,
did all kinds of blood works,
to again also ensure that it's not COVID
that it's not any viruses that can potentially...
The last thing you want to do is to push yourself when you
have this, or let's say you are having an infection that can
potentially call Myocarditis or other
long-term issues for you.
So I wanted to rule out all that and
then I kept daily dialogue with the team doctor
in Norway as well.
And as Kristian was starting to recover, unfortunately,
Gustav maybe has a little bit more exposed
because he also have asthma.
So coming to dry climates like St. George, we needed to,
started to use...
Yeah, try to moisturize the air, got humidifiers and so on.
Sorry, sorry, Kristian.
Imagine if you weren't sick before an Ironman,
what you could do.
(both Adam and Rich laughing)
That's two races, right?
You had the stomach thing in Cozumel and then this.
So hopefully third time lucky.
Isn't that what we're saying?
When we come coming to Hawaii, that would be my race.
You had an amazing race Kristian, congratulations.
What was going through your mind when you were kind of in
the no man's land on the bike and how close to,
according to plan, did everything go for you?
Yeah, so the swim,
I ideal should have been up there on the swim,
but I felt just so weak standing there on the start line.
So before the race, we had five minutes in where
we could warm up and after two minutes I started vomiting
cause my throat was so kind of bad and irritating.
So I felt quite, like I said,
I wasn't really on fire when I was waiting for gun to go
and had a weak swim two minutes or so behind,
tried to catch up.
I just lost time on the first 40, 50 K on the bike.
And so we went from like 230 to 330 and then I had
Cameron behind me and we were like 40 seconds behind,
but I thought, okay,
I'm just gonna let my computer and just refocus,
wait the guys behind and then give it one final shot
for the race.
Like, it's almost like I was giving up,
but I also tried to think that
it's not over until it's over, a typical Ironman mantra.
And just focusing on doing the nutrition,
getting in a lot of liquid and then carbs and more in,
just to be prepared for final half marathon.
So Olav during the race,
what is the sort of approach that you're taking as a coach?
What are you looking for?
What is the data that you're trying to extract from
Kristian's performance?
And when you guys get home and start, you know,
waiting through all of it,
what are you looking to learn and hone going into Kona in
the fall?
I think during the race,
because of the conditions and Kristian has not being
fully recovered from the race,
Gustav of course still too sick to race
or were it was not safe for him to race.
I actually didn't know what to expect going in there
because there are so many things that can happen.
And also because there was a lot of other people also that
were sick, I was act, I...
One of the things that I was pretty sure about was that the
dynamics of the race would be quite different than if you
had like a lot of the like
favorites that was all expected on the start line,
because then people don't want take equally bigger of risk.
Now, suddenly when a lot of them are out,
the podium is more open and people more willing to take risk
and it's like more make it or break it.
So actually we were able to work together with Adam,
the manager,
and we also had several of our tech partners there.
So they were asking of course the same question.
And I actually said that we just have to see,
first he needs to come out of the swim
if he comes out of the swim, okay.
And he goes on the bike, of course I get a glimpse
and I could see him.
Then you get at least, a little bit a feel of what
is like completely deflated or at least it's still game on.
And then already for the first part of the bike,
you get a good idea at least of, okay, how is the field?
Because it's more than looking at the tracker.
Because I don't have access to real time data.
So I have to follow the tracker and see how the rest of the
field plays out.
And when I saw that, first of course,
I saw the five guys in the front, they were riding hard.
I knew Kristian what numbers he had been doing
leading into the race.
So, and I know how strong he is.
So I knew that if people were starting to go much faster
than Kristian, I knew also they were probably over pacing.
But again, he's sick, so you don't know whether
they're going faster because they're going at
the order of pace or whether it's Kristian
going a little bit slower because he doesn't feel a 100%.
But then when I saw Cameron Wurf coming up
and Sanders coming up and I still see that the front group
of the five guys are still making room down to Kristian,
Cameron and Sanders, I knew Sanders was fresh.
He was healthy.
Cameron was healthy.
So I used them a little bit as a coach to understand a
little bit how fast the front group was riding.
And then also I saw that one of the guys that has been
running or been quite strong before, like Daniel Bækkegård,
I saw that he was starting to drop down to fifth position
in the group.
And that was like an indicator for me because he knew
he had to run probably fast also to be able to be
in position to do something.
And when I saw he fell down and was sitting
on the back of the group then I was thinking,
okay, now he's falling down to fifth position.
He's been running too hard,
he needs to or try to basically recover as much as possible,
so he's in position to able to run.
And then when they came out of the bike
and started to run of course Kristian looked sharp.
So then I was pretty confident already that, okay,
Kristian is gonna bring this home, so.
Kristian, what is that like for you?
Are you getting communications at all from Olav?
Are you just kind of, are you getting splits on your watch?
I saw you looking at your watch a lot on the run.
What were you looking at and how did it feel to finally pass
the leader at mile 18?
Yeah. So throughout the whole bike race,
you get very few...
Or you get a lot of splits from the people on the course,
but it's very, like,
you can't really trust the splits,
whether they're using just the...
taking the splits themselves,
or if they're just using old splits from the live tracker.
So it's quite confusing.
And there was only two people,
that I was in back section with
that I could take their splits myself.
So, but for the whole bike ride, basically,
I was just kind of getting negative feedback.
Like I was losing a little bit, a little bit,
little bit until maybe 100K, and from there on,
we were kind of staying within the four and a half minute
gap and was stabilizing there.
But ideally I wanted to kinda reach up again.
So coming into the run,
I wasn't sure like how my run mates would be,
but I felt quite smoked at some part of the bike ride
going up the two big climbs,
but I was thinking that if I go out on the run on my limits,
then at least it's kind giving it a try and at least running
for a podium, because no way that all five of those guys
will be kind of able to put the match all together.
So I was expecting some of them to burn up.
So of the beginning was just running for a podium.
And for the first 10K I think I was running in the same
speed as Braden Currie, the guy from New Zealand.
And I knew that he could be a very good runner and I kind of
thought, okay, thinking that he's maybe out of territory,
I can't really catch him.
But then on the way back again, I suddenly kind of
reached back two minutes out of those four and a half.
And then I was only two and a half minutes behind him with a
half marathon to go.
And that was kind the moment when I saw that I can actually
start winning this,
'cause like the pictures in my head of myself
winning the race.
And I just had to keep focus and making sure that
I still did the nutrition and hydration correctly
and took as much fluid as I could
in the aid station just to stay cool.
Amazing.
So Adam and I were talking before the podcast
about how cool and rare it is when somebody says,
"Here's what's gonna happen, here's what we're gonna do."
And then they actually go out and do it, right?
So--
Yes.
you did that.
The proof is in the pudding.
There's been a lot written about and spoken about
this unique approach to training and racing
that you guys have cultivated
in this amazing partnership through kind of, you know,
really understanding sports science and next level data
mining and all the interesting things that you're doing.
And that of course has resulted in a bit of a backlash.
There's a lot of shit talking out there
about the Norwegian train.
So I wanna give you the opportunity to
slap back a little bit.
Anything you wanna say to all those detractors out there
and any predictions about Kona and the kind of season that's
continuing to unfold.
I was actually thinking like two weeks ago
that if I'm able to win here at St. George,
then nobody has a chance in Hawaii.
So we'll see--
There it is.
(all laughing)
So we will be in five months if that's correct.
Because I didn't really prepared
and I will be prepared coming to Hawaii.
There, you have it.
Very exciting.
Congratulations to both of you guys.
It's really a treat.
Thanks for making this work.
Yeah, absolutely.
Really appreciate you guys taking the time,
it's been so fun, cheering you from afar
and watching all of this progress kind of unfold.
Can't wait to see what you do in Kona.
And at some point when you guys find yourselves in LA,
we'd love to have you in the studio for a full blown
podcast, if you can make the time.
Great.
Thank you, yeah.
All right, hopefully there's a parade waiting for you
in the Bergen airport when you land.
(Kristian and Olav laughing)
Yes.
We are landing just before midnight tomorrow, so...
(all laughing)
All right, cool.
Travel safe guys.
Thanks gentlemen.
Bye.
Thank you.
(logo whooshing)
Wasn't that awesome, talking to Kristian and Olav?
It was, it was amazing.
(both laughing)
We're laughing because we haven't recorded it yet.
We're pretending like we just had that experience.
Yeah we--
But you will.
You, the audience member will have had that experience.
You've had it, we have not.
I hope it was good.
I hope it was good for you.
There are a couple more stories
from the world of endurance.
We gotta talk about this six year old kid
who ran the Flying Pig Marathon in Cincinnati.
Right.
What's your hot take.
It's not really my business on whether a certain six year
old kid runs the Mar...
I'm not gonna be outraged by it or celebrated.
It's all, none of my business.
Is that a good hot take?
That is a hot take because you're kind of in the middle.
I mean, I'm like carry on.
Carry on with your lives.
I will not judge all of you.
This sort of led up the internet.
Yeah.
The other week,
a lot of people had a lot to say about this,
including people like Kelly Gaucher.
I had Stephen Magnuson here the other day
who's an elite track and field coach.
He had some not so nice words about the--
Is it a bad thing to do?
Well at six years old
Right.
It's not a great idea.
No.
And I think there was some indication,
obviously I wasn't there, I don't know the parents,
the parents are defending their decision,
but there was some video and some sense that the kid was
crying and like not to do it.
And like they kind of urged him to complete it.
Oh, that's different.
All of that, whether or not that's true or not,
I'm not sure, but it's certainly somewhat controversial.
And I don't think you can make the argument
that it's healthy for a six year old to run a marathon.
Certainly if there's pressure on that young person,
apparently it's a family full of very active people who are
strivers and they all did the marathon together.
So was there pressure on this young person to complete it,
in order to kind of get that parental approval.
Who knows, but
Right.
maybe not wise,
I think it would be prudent for race organizers to be more
conscious about age minimums and, you know,
protecting the young people out there.
Mm.
So I just, you know
I'm all for like getting young people out there and active
and doing challenges,
but I just don't think that at that age,
something that challenging is in the child's best interest.
Fair enough.
That's my hot take.
Good.
Can we celebrate Jacky Hunt-Broersma
she completed her 104 marathons in 100 consecutive days.
Unbelievable.
Setting the record for the most marathons run
on consecutive days by a woman.
And she did it as an amputee.
She's been an amputee for five years.
She lost the lower part of her left leg to cancer.
She's also 46 years old and a mom,
and she did it to raise money.
And she raised quite a bit of money.
By latest amount in her GoFundMe looks like she's
raised $194,080.
And those funds are directed towards this amputee
prosthetics charity called Amputee Blade Runners,
because those blades like that, you see her,
if you're watching this on YouTube,
the kind of blade that she's running on
Yep.
Are super expensive.
They're like 10 to 20 grand each.
And insurance doesn't necessarily cover them.
So, you know, to be able to create a fund that will make
that more widely accessible to other active minded amputees,
I think is pretty cool.
I agree.
Super inspiring.
She was sharing the whole thing on social media every day.
And on marathon, fantastic shout out to RXBAR
that matched donations up to $104,000, which is
what they donated to her GoFundMe.
So if you wanna learn more about Jacky,
if you wanna support her GoFundMe,
there's links in the show notes,
you can find her @ncrunnerjacky
J-A-C-K-Y on Instagram.
And there's a bunch of news stories.
And we'll link those up in the show notes as well,
including this piece in ESPN, which is pretty cool, so.
Very cool piece.
So much love Jacky.
Yes, and shout out to moms.
I didn't get to do my mother's day thing as she's a mom.
So I'm gonna take my appreciate...
she used to like get the kids to school and then she was
going off on marathons every day, like that was her rhythm.
She dropped her kid off at school
and then she'd run a marathon
and try to finish it in time to go pick her kid up.
Right, right, and so I just wanna say if it wasn't for you
moms, we'd all still we'd be cavemen.
If it wasn't for the moms,
we'd all still be cavemen is my point.
At least the males would.
Well, you wouldn't exist.
Well, there's that.
But I mean, I, don't mean the biological function
of motherhood.
Oh.
You just mean, you just an unrefined...
We'd be wild beasts.
Yeah, I hear you.
Yeah.
I bet even like the first cave painter, if it was a male,
I bet the first cave painter was just like
this goth vegan cave man that didn't want to go hunting--
I doubt, I doubt, I doubt vegan.
And just lays it around the cave until his wife said,
"You know what, do something useful."
"Either you paint that cave or you're outta here."
(both laughing)
Do something with your time.
I didn't not marry you for this.
Right.
Let's talk about William Goodge.
Let's do it.
You love William Goodge.
So we brought him up the other week because he is the
model slash ultra runner slash hype beast dude,
who supported Robbie Balenger in his effort to outlast the
Tesla in the hill country of Texas the other week.
But Robbie had previously supported William in his effort to
complete 48 marathons in 30 days,
which was a challenge that he set out to accomplish,
to memorialize his mother who died of cancer and to raise
money for the McMillan Cancer Support, which is a
a cancer charity in the UK.
And there's a documentary that just came out about the 48/30
it's called 48/30.
You can find it on Amazon here's if you're watching on
YouTube,
here's a little link to the film.
William posted a trailer for the video on his Instagram that
I shared the other day.
And it's pretty cool.
So shout out to William,
check out the movie and all sales of the movie
or rental fees for the movie go directly to
McMillan Cancer Support.
So it's basically a charitable affair
and a cool movie to boot.
Also, I thought it was cool that he's a WHOOP athlete
and WHOOP has this blog post,
where they chronicled the strain of running 48 marathons
in 30 days.
So they kind of tell his story
and then they have all of his data.
Amazing.
Which is pretty interesting to kind of take a look at,
it's also cool how WHOOP is doing more and more of this.
Like, they've got whoops on a lot of the cyclists
from this one day classics, and then you can kind of go
and look at the data and see what the strain is and all that
sort of stuff, which I think is--
If you wanna geek out on your favorite athletes.
Yeah you can geek out on all that kinda stuff.
I like that, that's really cool.
Yeah, man, what else you got from me?
I got this wonderful surf photography book.
It's an art book by Clark Little, "The Art of Waves"
Clark Little is one of the great surf photographers,
came up I think with the Kelly Slater crew and all them
and Kelly Slater actually has a really well written forward
to this book.
And it's quite something,
a lot of it is shore break, there's some landscape stuff,
but I mean, the overarching idea is to get
the reader or viewer into a barrel.
And he does that so many different ways.
Like I've never actually...
You could see it in films, you kind of see it, but like,
there's something about the still photography of actually
getting to get that perspective of being barreled.
Oh, that's a cool one.
which most of us will never experience.
So I love that about this--
That's exactly what it looks like when I'm in the barrel.
Yeah this is what it looks like when Rich
is getting barrel.
Yeah.
So I love it, I think it's really a great piece of work.
The writing is exceptional.
It's by Jamie Brisick does a lot of the writing or it does,
I guess with Clark,
they collaborated, so congratulations.
Did it just come out.
Just came out.
Oh, nice.
It's available everywhere.
Congratulations to Clark and thanks for the book.
Cool.
It's awesome.
And you got one more thing you wanted to share, right?
And then the month of May 100 mile challenge.
So there is a nonprofit called Giveback Homes.
They are a charity founded and run
by two former Tom's employees.
One, a guy named Blake Andrews and Caroline Pennell.
Who's a Rich Roll podcast listener, sister Priscilla Vega,
a friend of mine and who does PR in the environmental and
social entrepreneurial space.
And they basically came up with a Tom style business.
Well, not business, theirs is a nonprofit
where they take the profits from real estate companies,
and they use them to build homes for poor, disadvantaged,
marginal communities and families in the US and abroad.
A lot of times it's in Central America.
And so they partnered with real estate agents,
brokerages companies,
the agency which is a Southern California real estate,
I guess agency was their first partnership
and the agency is raising money through
this month of May 100 mile challenge.
They have a group on the Nike Run app.
And that group is where you can kind of join.
And it's not too late, even though it's already May,
it's not too late.
And a lot of you runners can throw down a 100 miles
in three weeks, so the idea is you give
$30 donation a minimum on the agency's website
and we have the link for you and that $30 donation,
then you can also join.
So you can also just donate.
I've donated, I'm not in the Nike Run group,
but I'm gonna do 100 miles, you can follow that.
That's gonna happen for me on Strava.
I just don't carry my phone with me everywhere.
So I'm not doing the run group,
but that you could do it any way you like,
and even Caroline has said,
if you're curious about joining one of these
build out trips, they do them all the time.
They call 'em I guess
the groups of volunteers that's who builds them.
And so you can join, they're right now
in El Salvador in one week building some homes.
And so it's like a habitat for humanity.
Right, like a Jimmy Carter, yeah.
Right, right, right.
That's cool.
So that's that.
How long does it take 'em to build a home?
I guess they build several homes in a week, yeah.
Cause if she's there May 5th to 9th.
Like that's only four days.
They're gonna have some homes built.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how or why--
It's a great idea.
Yeah, it's cool right.
Nice, and do we want to throw her email?
She put her email, you put her email on that.
Yeah, So caroline@givebackhomes.com
if you're interested,
if you don't go to the show notes,
if you're interested in these trips,
and wanna be a part of it.
Caroline, spelt the traditional way @givebackhomes.com.
Mm, cool.
(logo whooshing)
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about the
importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know how to
eat better and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience some version of
what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the plant power meal planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands of
highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery and
you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout,
this is life changing stuff people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off and annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Alright, well, why don't we turn our focus and attention to,
you know, current events,
things that are on everybody's mind right now,
obviously is what's happening with the potential overturning
of Roe versus Wade.
This is what everybody's talking about.
This leaked draft opinion in Dobs versus Jackson Women's
Health Organization found its way to POLITICO.
And that story was published about a week ago, I think.
Mm.
It lit the internet on fire and has really monopolized the
news cycle.
And look, you know, how do we talk about abortion?
How do we talk about the right to choose, the right to life
and balance those considerations in a way that's nuanced
and respectful.
I mean, everybody has their opinion on this
and their philosophical perspective.
I'm certainly not here to change anybody's mind.
I happen to be pro-choice, I have been for a very long time,
I believe in a woman's right to choose.
And the fact that this draft decision,
which we have every reason to believe while it's been
legitimized by Alito as the real thing.
Obviously it's a draft, so whatever happens.
And when it gets published,
will I assume be at least slightly different than what we've
all seen to date, is gonna change the lay of the land
in terms of a woman's right to choose.
And I think there are far reaching implications to this.
I think it's interesting.
Listen, I'm no constitutional scholar,
but I did take constitutional law.
I gotta B in law school.
Oh.
And it--
So you're now getting some analysis from a guy
that got a B in constitutional law.
So basically what I'm saying is don't listen to me,
but I do think it's, you know,
rather than like having a hyperbolic conversation about
this, like let's look at what this decision
was premised upon.
And I think it's interesting that the opinion emanates from
a perspective of not being persuaded by the due process
clause of the 14th amendment,
which is kind of what Roe versus Wade rests on.
The idea that within the due process clause,
there is this right to liberty and how strictly or broadly
do we construe what liberty is.
Can it be inferred from the founders or from the
constitutional text that from that we can create
this zone of privacy, right?
Well, Roe versus Wade says, "Yes"
Alito and the five justices who are overturning Roe versus
Wade say, "Not so fast."
It's a much stricter constitutional interpretation,
which is what conservatives do.
They're strict constitutionalists.
So this is what they're basing this opinion on.
It's also interesting that it is
a shirking of stare decisis.
Stare decisis being this preference that
we give to settle law.
Like if it's settled, we give it respect.
And we're reluctant to overturn something that has been
properly considered in the past.
Mm.
In the past,
when old settled law decisions have been reversed,
particularly in the civil rights sphere,
it's traditionally been to expand rights,
but here we have for,
I think the very first time a shirking of stare decisis
deployed to restrict rights.
And that's settled law,
meaning the Supreme Court has ruled and then sometimes it
was challenged and then ruled again.
So after two rulings, is that considered settled law?
I mean, I guess it depends on how you interpret that.
But in the case of Roe versus Wade,
we're talking decades,
right?
Right.
It's been 40 or 50 years
of it being considered settled law.
And interestingly in the confirmation hearings of many of
these Trump appointees,
they commented that Roe versus Wade was settled law.
I know, they lied.
You know, they said that, and now here we are.
Yes.
You know, Trump packing the Supreme Court,
this was the plan all along.
And now we're seeing the results of, you know,
those seeds that were sewn quite some time ago.
I think what's also interesting about this
is the extent to which this could ultimately unravel other
rights, like same sex marriage.
I know you have thoughts on that.
Yep.
And I think it's important just so we're all
on the same page and understand what we're
talking about here.
This doesn't outlaw abortion.
It just prevents the federal government from making federal
law regarding the policing of abortion.
So essentially allows States to write their own laws.
Yep.
It's gonna trigger laws in States that have laws that
are preexisting that will go into effect upon publication.
And of course this will have a disproportionate impact on
poor people and people of color,
particularly obviously in Red States.
Yep.
And I think it's interesting that this more restrictive or
limited read of liberty or how we're defining liberty or
thinking about liberty, the parameters of liberty
are inconsistent with the other issues that conservatives
or the right tend to care care about.
Like they want liberty when it comes to opposing mandates,
for example, we've all seen that.
And yet when it comes to women bodies and the unborn child,
they wanna undercut the woman's liberty.
So there is an inconsistency in that perspective or
prioritization of liberty, depending upon, you know,
who would be embodying that liberty, right.
And also, I mean, obviously it's a different amendment,
but right to bear arms, they want liberty
when it comes to guns,
They want liberty when it comes to their choices,
they're in favor of,
and they don't want liberty in this case.
And you know, there is some quid pro quo because
the people who say it's my body, my choice,
when it comes to abortion,
aren't really stoked when people didn't wanna wear masks.
So there is a back and forth grade area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you know--
Because human beings are inconsistent and emotional and
irrational when it comes to these sorts of things.
And you have what, it looks like 19 States already
have laws that will go into effect after this thing is
published 22 to 26 States might have some issue.
Right.
I think that there's still gonna be like
morning after pills, still on the market in those States.
Let's just kind of put out there.
There's still access to prescription drugs that could
help assist in unwanted pregnancy cases.
Yeah, but I think it may,
it's interesting because in a certain way you can say,
"Well, we're moving backwards.
"We're going back to the 1930s."
But it's not a situation in which there's gonna be coat
hangers and back alleyways.
Right.
Like a lot of abortions are,
as I understand it, conducted through prescription.
Like through a medication, a pharmaceutical, right.
So the question then becomes,
how restrictive is that medication and or what does the
black market look like in terms of getting your hands on
that medication?
And what happens when somebody who isn't qualified is
administering that medication or taking that medication
because people aren't gonna stop getting abortions.
It's just a question of how they're gonna be getting
abortions.
And I think it's interesting that we're seeing these...
It's almost like, now that this is out,
all these people feel emboldened to start talking about
other laws that are even more extreme, like
preventing pregnant women who are in these States
where abortion is gonna be outlawed from crossing State
lines.
You've seen new stories about the potential illegality of
contraception, IUDs, condoms.
I mean, I can't imagine that,
but is this the world that we're now entering?
I'm not sure, but it is strange.
It's strange, and it is a law that I think, you know,
I think this decision really took everybody by surprise.
I think everybody just thought this is settled law.
The day would never come when Roe versus Wade would be
overturned.
And yet this has been the conservative agenda for a very
long time.
And now they're seeing it finally come to fruition.
It's happened.
I think there's a couple things,
there are gonna be more children.
There's an economist at Middlebury College in Vermont named
Caitlin Knowles Myers who has studied for 15 years,
the impact of restrictive abortion laws on women.
And it basically in her...
She wrote a paper in 2017 that basically expanded access to
abortion has reduced teen motherhood by 34%,
reduced teen brides by 20%,
that she estimates 75,000 more births within a year
to people who have otherwise considered abortion.
The big thing that I keep hearing and I think is legitimate
is you are basically now forcing to...
because of this one particular opinion that let's face it is
rooted in religion.
You are now potentially forcing women to carry a
baby for nine months, deliver that baby.
And in some cases, unless they're, you know,
okay with trying to put it up for adoption,
which is its own traumatic experience,
then raising the child sometimes as a single mom.
So it's like you are controlling the life of women
because of your religious beliefs.
How is that any different from some of the stuff that
we're outraged about?
I mean, it's outrageous.
It is what it is.
I don't look down on people's religious beliefs,
but I don't expect your religious belief to then impact me.
And so that's where I look at that.
And in terms of, I don't...
I'm not an alarmist.
So this idea that it is going to, you know,
same sex marriage is next and contraception is after that.
I don't actually think that will happen.
I don't even think same sex marriage
is going to be overturned.
But the way this ruling is written in the draft form,
anyway, it certainly opens the door for that.
And that's what's alarming and there's now talk,
they've actually open the door to overturn other laws.
There is a story outta Texas that the governor there wants
to what's his name, Greg...
Abbott,
Greg Abbot.
The governor now wants to sue, to overturn a federal law
that was settled at the Supreme Court level that demands
that Texas educate the children of illegal immigrants in
Texas their children may not get educated in
public schools there because of it.
If he goes through this lawsuit,
he talked about it at a press conference.
He gave his legal opinion on how and why it could be
overturned.
They have not filed suit yet.
The State of Texas hasn't done that yet.
But when I see this, which 70% of United States is against
the overturning of Roe v Wade, 70%, you noticed
there's no bragging going on in the Republican Party.
Nobody is like, bragging we finally did.
No one is celebrating.
No because it's so out of step with what polls indicate
where the temperature of the American people are.
So you have that, and then you have actually this impulse,
whether it's the lawsuit happens or not this impulse to
actually weaponize young children and the education of
children, it makes me think two things.
One is who runs for office to gain power to do that,
like what is in the head of a person who runs for office
and their big goal is to not educate kids, that's crazy.
And the second is to me, whether it happens now 10 years,
15 years, this is the beginning of the end
of the Republican Party.
That's what I think.
I think everything's gonna be okay, I'm not an alarmist.
I think it's all gonna be okay.
And I think this is gonna be the beginning of the end of the
Republican Party.
Well, it's certainly going to activate the Democrats
and it's gonna marshal the interest of the independents.
There's a lot of people in the middle who are undecided or
waffle between parties, depending upon the election cycle
and who's running,
but this is such an emotional issue.
And I think it's really gonna innovate certain aspects of
the population who have been traditionally apathetic about
their kind of, you know,
sort of citizenship and their enthusiasm around voting.
Yeah.
The Democrats generally bundle these types of
opportunities to marshal support.
Yes.
So we'll see what happens,
but it's certainly an opportunity going into the midterms.
And I think the kind of domino effect or downstream
implications of this decision,
which we're expecting will come out sometime in the next
seven weeks.
I think every time that we're in that position where the...
Because the Supreme court rules like once or twice a week,
right.
On something every time they're about to make a ruling,
I'm like, is this gonna be it?
Is this real?
Is interesting because at least with respect
to the same sex marriage issue,
although Alito says explicitly in the draft opinion
that this should not be construed beyond the very special
case of abortion, because it involves the unborn life.
And shouldn't be, you know
the kind of underscoring law and the principles
beneath their argument, shouldn't be extrapolated
to apply to other issues.
It's not a stretch to see how those legal arguments or the
kind of logical through line that runs through
this majority opinion could not then be applied to same sex
marriage and other civil rights issues.
It could.
That we could see becoming unraveled as a result of this.
So it's interesting, I think it's also interesting
that I'm not sure that the Republican Party
is actually prepared for what will actually happen if this
becomes law,
because with the increase in the childbirth rate and the
other things that you were just mentioning,
we're gonna need federal and State programs to help manage
all of this, right.
And the right is less enthusiastic about funneling money
into government programs to support these young mothers and
the children, particularly, you know,
if they wanna put them up for adoption and the like.
Like we're gonna need social service support in order to
manage this.
The right doesn't like to give social service report.
Yeah, I mean, support.
So, right.
So all these people fall through the cracks.
That's right, I mean, it's the same thing
with school children,
like actually their presence in schools gives public school
money, you know like you take people out,
you actually hurt your own schools.
It's always been it's a folding in of the fabric
of the country.
And it's because of me, mine, and this is what I believe
so there, you know,
that kind of attitude has been the kind of on the
conservative side for a long time.
Now, on the other side of it, it's like, you know,
we don't want to overstate a winning argument.
We don't want to say this means, you know,
these other rights are going to be taken away cause it's not
necessarily true.
So like, I would just urge people who are having these
discussions or posting about it or whatever,
let's stick to the facts.
And the facts of the case are look like Roe is gonna be
overturned.
Let's just talk about that because we, you know,
until the other things are actually under threat,
the only reason I brought up the Texas situation
is 'cause it's under threat because
Greg Abbott spoke about it.
So that's why I bring it up.
But the other ones we'll see.
I mean, certainly the ruling leaves it open to possibility,
but if it's just Roe alone, that's already, you know,
a lot of people are extremely troubled by it and 70% of the
population disagrees with it.
So, you know, it's a very bizarre thing
to be kind of living through, yeah.
More will be revealed.
And just so you're not under the impression
that I'm some kind of left wing, progressive chill.
I think it's important to point out that,
although I'm pro-choice,
I'm not so crazy about this new Biden administration
Ministry of Truth, the disinformation governance board,
this is news to you, right?
Like you weren't aware of this is going on.
I wasn't aware.
And it's a very bad title.
Yeah, it really is.
It's a very bad title.
(Adam laughing)
I mean, there's literally...
Like the name of an Orwell biography is "Ministry of Truth"
Right.
Like it could not be more Orwell in that regard.
It couldn't be a worse title who writes their titles--
The disinformation governance board.
It's interesting, 'cause this came out right in the wake,
if I have my timeline right,
of this speech that Obama recently gave at Stanford on
misinformation and disinformation, did you see that?
No I saw snippets of it.
I did not watch the little speech.
I mean, it's obviously, it is a problematic issue.
We do need smart people thinking about
how to solve this problem.
I'm not saying it's not a problem.
I'm just not crazy about this being part of the solution.
Interesting side note.
I was up in the bay area when I went to go to
that doctor for my back appointment.
Yeah.
And I took Jaya with me and
I was giving a tour of like the...
I was like, here's where I went to college
and we were driving around Stanford.
And then as we're exiting, like behind Stanford,
there was two cop cars and then four black SUVs and then
another two cop cars.
And I was like, somebody's in those?
You know, I was like, who is that?
Right.
Like it turned out it was Obama 'cause he had just spoken
at Stanford--
Barack Obama day.
So that was my somewhat fleeting experience being close
to Barack Obama, anyway--
Not as close as to Larry Ellison buying cough drops.
Yeah. So this disinformation governance board
is within the department of Homeland Security.
And the problem is that it's run by people, right?
And people obviously are prone to being emotional and
partisan and susceptible to incentives.
And the person who's been appointed to run this
Nina Jankowicz is a very inherently partisan person.
I mean she's an advocate for online regulation and stiffer
action against online abuse, fine.
But it's tricky, man.
You know, when you get the government involved in saying
what's disinformation and what's misinformation,
alarm bells go off appropriately.
Now in fairness, the intention behind all of this
is to identify and combat international threats
like coming from Russia and China,
Right.
This is something that Jankowicz has experience with
like this is her ex level of expertise.
Okay.
But anytime you vest a government department
or organization with the power to make conclusions
about what's true and what isn't,
we should all be concerned about that.
Yeah, no doubt.
And it seems like it actually opens you up to
vulnerabilities politically by even getting involved in
that, you know like, so yeah, it doesn't sound good.
I wouldn't want a Ministry of Truth judging what...
like, first of all, there's so much content.
There's no way they could even--
I know.
Who's gonna judge it all, is gonna be AI.
Who's controlling the AI.
I mean it's so inherently problematic.
It seems like the issue is an upstream issue.
Let's fight misinformation before it happens.
Let's fight...
You know like where does this lead?
I mean you have misinformation every day because we have a
completely open media landscape now, you know, is it--
It's hard, it's a really hard problem.
On the one hand, it's incumbent upon all of us
to be better filters of information and to develop and hone
our critical thinking skills,
that should be taught in schools now.
Right.
Given the fact that every kid is exposed to so much stuff,
they need to understand how to distinguish between reality
and fantasy disinformation et cetera.
But we're also, you know,
walking forward into this dystopian technological era of
deep fakes and you know,
what happens when technology advances to the point where you
could put a video out of some head of State who looks and
sounds exactly like the head of State who's sitting on top
of nuclear arsenal, and he says,
"I'm gonna launch a first strike."
Like there are real world implications to this.
That kind of make it feel like,
well probably there should be some government organization
that's paying attention to this.
So I understand that, but at the same time, like
it's pretty difficult to figure out
how you solve this problem.
Yeah.
I mean, it depends on what the structure is
like what are they actually looking at.
What's the purview.
And then I think your criticism of who's in charge of it.
It should look pretty impartial.
It should look more impartial than that.
You know like when--
Or at least it shouldn't be one person.
Yeah, and maybe it's not, you know, like maybe it's not,
I haven't really looked at it, but it doesn't sound...
It sounds like it could be used to accuse the government of
censorship and you don't wanna be censoring right now.
It's just like, I'm against censorship.
You are too, we're free speech people.
So I wish there was a way to solve this problem without
structure on speech.
And hopefully there is.
We'll see.
When Elon takes over Twitter.
Maybe Elon can solve all these problems.
Well, I think he thinks he can.
(both laughing)
Let's get Elon over there.
You know, now that Elon's a Texan,
he can have a sit down with Greg Abbott and--
I'm sure he's had one, at least one.
At least one already.
Of course.
Yeah, well he shouldn't be in favor of this.
I mean, his Giga-factory out there is like
the largest building in the world.
A crazy gigantic building that goes on forever and ever.
How come you, don't a Gigafactory?
I have a Gigafactory in my mind.
All right, let's go to listener questions.
We're gonna do one question and then we're gonna pivot
to our second zoom call with Chris Hauth.
Hey Adam, hey Rich.
My name is Tristan Dukes.
I'm calling from Orem, Utah.
And my question is so we're in a world of a lot of
information.
There's a lot of podcasts and you know,
a lot of things that I'm constantly learning
and I would argue a lot of healthy things
that I'm learning in your podcast.
And there's so many things that I wanna implement
in my life.
Like I'd like to be more plant based.
I'd like to stay consistent with intermittent fasting and
those health benefits.
And the list goes on is like things that I'd like to do or,
oh, I should sleep between this time and get this, you know,
but I can't help, but feel overwhelmed at times
with how much information or how many things
that I should be doing or, you know, well,
I shouldn't be eating fish because it's not sustainable.
And I feel like it's to my detriment and I try and focus on
that 1% better every day.
But ultimately I do feel overwhelmed with all the different
things out in the world and the way that I can better
myself.
And I guess I'm just wondering if you have any tips
tricks to bettering yourself in a way that is sustainable,
and that I can grow in ways that I can measure.
Yeah. Thank you guys.
Thank you Tristan.
Orem is where they Iron Cowboy lives.
That's right, Iron Cowboy
who's going to Utila.
Oh, he is.
He's gonna race the World Championship in Utila.
Oh, good for him, oh, that's fantastic.
Yeah. Isn't that cool.
Fun to see him do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's great.
He'll love it, I think he'll love it.
Yeah, spent a lot of time in Orem.
It's a beautiful place in the world.
So thank you for your question, Tristan.
Yeah, it's like I relate to this a lot.
It's like a classic case of whataboutism
like every time you're doing a good thing,
then you can think of the 10 things that you're not doing.
Well, I should be doing this and I should be doing that.
And you can easily turn that into, you know,
kind of a self-flagellation parade,
which I've been known to do to myself because it is so
all, you know, all consuming and overwhelming
when you hear all this high vibration content and people are
saying, do this, do that, do that.
I mean, every week hosting this podcast,
I learn new things from my guests
and the other content that I consume.
And it's impossible to incorporate all of it or synthesize
it into my life or for anybody to do that.
So you gotta be a little bit more sort of gracious with
yourself I think,
because if you did set yourself up to try to follow
everything, for example, just take morning routines.
Like everybody likes to talk about morning routines.
Like, well, if you did everything everybody told you to do
for your morning routine,
it would take you like three hours to do it every day.
Like it's not sustainable--
Yeah man, I don't have time.
To stare into the sun when you wake up in the morning.
I can't stare into the sun that long, yeah.
It's like all of 'em are also like,
it'll only take you a few minutes,
but if you like made a list of,
okay, I gotta stare in the sun,
I gotta drink water with apple cider vinegar.
Then I gotta do my meditation, and then I gotta do my
journaling, and then I gotta do my visualization, and then I
gotta do my gratitude list.
And then I gotta do my stretches or my, you know, it's--
When's time to work.
Like.
(Adam laughing)
Right, exactly.
Right.
And I think, you know, I love,
I wanted to say that like I love that, you know,
try to be 1% better every day mantra.
I think that's cool.
And it's very like simplistic.
So you can wrap your head around it,
but it actually isn't true.
Like, I don't think anybody gets 1% better every day
because improvement is not linear, let alone exponential.
Life is messy and we make mistakes.
And most days it's, you know, two steps backwards--
I got 4% worse yesterday.
Did you?
No.
All the making up, it'd be great
like if there was an app and all it said,
it just gave you a percent every day of how much better or
worse you are than the day before.
Olav could figure that out, he could tell us--
You're 4% worse today.
Like I don't even need specifics just, yeah bad.
It's not good.
Yesterday was bad, you're 15% the man you used to be.
Right.
Yeah, the pressure of that, right?
I gotta be 1% better every day.
It's the pressure of unrealistic proportions.
And so I think a better way to think about this,
that hopefully might be helpful to you Tristan
and put your mind at ease a little bit is to just,
first of all, create a hierarchy of needs,
like do a self inventory and try to identify what is most
dire or in terms of your need to redress in your life.
Like, what is most urgent?
Like where is that limited bandwidth time and focus best
invested that will kind of be this fulcrum
to leverage the most change.
'Cause you can't do everything.
And if you set yourself up to do too many things,
you're going to fail for the reasons
that you're already aware.
So, you know, do that inventory and inventory
your nutrition, your fitness, your mental health,
your career, your relationships,
how involved you are in your community,
what does your spiritual life look like?
And really be honest with yourself and try to figure out
like, okay, where am I the most off the mark?
Or where is the area that I really haven't been
giving the care and attention that it deserves.
And I think once you focus on that one thing and start to
channel that focus in that direction,
the cool thing is that it then opens up all kinds of other
stuff because you're performing in estimable
act for yourself,
which breeds self-esteem and gets you more emotionally
connected and enthusiastic about improving other areas of
your life.
For example, if you pick diet and you start
improving your diet,
you start feeling better.
Maybe you lose a little bit of weight,
you're gonna feel better, and then you're gonna be like,
I deserve good things in my life.
Where else can I improve?
Because improvement feels good.
But I think the important thing is to do something
it's not necessarily what that thing is,
as much as it is about the fact that you are in action
and not falling prey to analysis paralysis,
because you have this avalanche of inputs that are pulling
you in a million different directions.
Like the perfection is the enemy
of the good, type of thing.
Yeah, exactly.
But that's something should be specific.
It should be measurable.
It should be quantifiable.
It should be time oriented.
And it can be a small thing like
10 minutes of meditation a day.
But as long as you're specific and you hold yourself to it,
you're accountable to it, I think that is the key thing.
And let go of this,
whatever compulsion or need you have to like make sure that
you're doing all of the things.
So an example that I often give is when I got sober,
like I was like, I have to change my whole life.
Like my life is a train wreck, it's a disaster.
I need to change my diet and my career.
And like I need new friends and in truth,
all I needed to do then was to just stop drinking
or not drink.
And so I focused on that because I was told,
I was like, I need to do all, no, forget about all that.
That will come in time.
Right now what you need to do is take care
of the biggest crisis in your life,
which is the fact that you can't stop drinking,
address that, and in time you will get healthier and
you'll be more capable of addressing those other areas
in your life.
But I wouldn't have been successful if
or been able to achieve the things that I have been able
to achieve if I'd tried to do all of it at one time.
Yeah.
So those are my thoughts.
You're so good at these.
You really are.
You're good at these they're thorny questions.
This is a great question by the way, because it, you know,
it's something it's close to like
we've had overwhelmed questions before,
but usually about how the world seems to be
in bit of a shit storm, this one's more internal like,
and you know, content that's coming at you,
what do you do with it all?
How do you catch it all?
I really like this question, Tristan.
And I think--
Yeah, I think anybody who listens to a lot of
like sort of self help self-improvement content
or reads a lot of those books,
you can get really disoriented because there's a lot of
things to do and a lot of things to think about.
Yeah.
So.
Great, great answers.
So, yeah.
Thanks for the question.
And that's it, I think we did it.
Call us guys send in some more questions.
Oh, that's right.
Should we leave the voicemail?
The voicemail phone number.
Four twenty four
you don't know it off head?
Do do I know it by heart? No.
Yeah, you don't know.
I have it right here. 4242354626.
That's right, it's 424--
Operators are standing by.
4242354626.
AI is standing by.
Right.
Yeah, we love the questions.
So keep 'em coming, appreciate it,
Adam and I will be back here in two weeks.
We're gonna celebrate the 10th anniversary
of "Finding Ultra"
so I have some fun stuff to share.
Oh nice.
That's been 10 years since that book came out.
That's awesome.
So we're gonna do a little giveaway kind of thing.
We'll talk about that.
When's the last time you read it.
Long time ago when I rewrote it a couple years ago.
Yeah, you did a revise, right?
I did a revise, yeah.
You did a reissue.
But it's been 10 years and it's been cool because it still
sells and it still tracks on Amazon.
And that's the most gratifying thing
'cause it wasn't a New York Times best seller.
It wasn't like a huge deal when it came out, but it's still,
you know, getting into hands of people.
And it's also interesting that despite its success,
the number of people that have read that book is still
a tiny segment of the podcast population.
Right.
Which shows you like how many people aren't reading books.
Yeah, read more podcast population.
Yeah.
Some of us rely on...
(both laughing)
Some of us.
I need you to read more, I have bills, right?
Cool, so we'll see you in two weeks and now we're gonna
go to my conversation with Chris.
I'm gonna share about my back situation with him.
Hopefully you have some words of wisdom for me as I try to
my wrap my head around whether I'm gonna do this
20 kilometer race coming up in a month.
Hmm.
Which is frightening me.
Yeah. Well, I'm eager to hear what he says
and I'm sorry you're having some pain.
It's okay, man.
I have some icy on my car.
Do you and I could use that.
And one of those old school,
like electric cord pad heating pads, remember those?
Oh you do?
(both laughing)
Yeah, I've got three in my car.
You want one?
No I'm okay.
Okay.
All right.
Thanks man, see you in two weeks.
All right, see you then.
Peace.
(logo whooshing)
How you feeling?
I've been better?
Mm, well.
Such is life, life is not linear.
It is not linear.
And the thing is, I believe as I wrote you,
I think muscle memory and how this all works and your
ability and open water and just your calmness in that
and not overthinking it.
You can do it.
I hear you.
And I'm not a verse to the Jesse Itzler school
of approaching, you know, crazy endurance events.
And I know that I do have, you know,
a background and a muscle memory.
And even as the volume was starting to increase,
like in the pool, the volume's never a problem with me.
Like I can increase the volume, no problem.
It's the intensity of the workouts that drain me.
And I'm totally fine for showing up
and just spinning the wheel.
But I need to calibrate that against whether I'm actually
doing damage because my back was so bad.
Like today's a little bit better, but the last four days,
like I literally can't stand up straight and
the amount of pain shooting through my back is unbelievable.
And there's no way that it's not tied to the swimming.
And it's probably mostly due to the turns.
But I think as the workouts started to get progressively
harder, I couldn't get around it anymore.
And it's been excruciating.
And so I haven't swum in like four days at this point.
Hmm, that's a bummer.
That's a bummer.
But the fact that this comes up from swimming
is such a new aspect of it, right?
Like I've had back issues before and like I'm sitting in the
chair here and I'll get up and I'll like fall to my knees.
'Cause I'm like this shooting, like pain just grips me.
And then I'm walking over around real hunched for a few
minutes and have to stand somewhere.
So it's not unfamiliar.
But to me it's never been a swimming question.
Don't get me wrong, I jump in the pool and I'm very timid.
And by the time I get going,
I'm probably doing some open turns or just not a lot of
extraneous movements,
but it usually always settles in on the swimming
now running, forget it.
Right.
Done, I can't get on a bike.
Eventually I can get on a bike,
but then I can't get off the bike.
Right.
(Chris laughing)
This is aging.
Yes.
Everybody watching and listening beware.
Yeah. So,
and the only other question for you is also do you go all
that way to do something where we inherently know you can do
it, but I think the value of an adventure and an experience
and something like this is, it creates some momentum and it
creates some powerful lasting energy within you.
Yeah, I think I just,
I hear all that and I appreciate it.
I think I just need to see over the next week or so,
whether that's realistic, like again,
I just don't want to do increased damage to my back.
And I am like in the midst of this protocol where I have an
opportunity to heal it with these doctors up your way,
and I wanna make sure that I'm following their advice
because short of this working,
like I'm looking at fusion surgery,
which obviously I wanna avoid at all costs.
So I don't want to do anything that's gonna slow down
this recovery process or impede it in any material way.
All things being neutral.
Yeah. I'll go do some crazy thing
and see if I can finish it.
I just don't wanna have any kind of permanent or
semipermanent damage as a result of being an idiot about
like, you know, how I'm healing my back.
Yeah, are they saying this is all expected?
Like what you're struggling with is part of the protocol
slash what could be part of it?
Well, what they said was that it's a slow process.
It's not gonna happen overnight.
It's probably gonna take about six months and, you know,
two to three appointments where I go through this procedure
and to temper my expectations of feeling any different in
the short term.
But they have seen good results as long as, you know,
I'm doing what I'm being told to do.
And then I'm patient with the whole thing,
but they didn't make any guarantees either.
They're like, you know, this is all kind of new stuff also,
all I can tell you is that we've seen people who are in a
similar situation that you're in
and they've seen tremendous progress.
And in terms of training, they're like, don't run.
If you can ride your bike without significant pain,
that's probably okay, swimming's fine.
Don't do flip turns.
And I've sort of partially taken that advice.
Like I have tried to do some tender flip turns and I think
it is the arching of the back and the flipping over and
the pushing off the wall,
that's probably the primary culprit and what I'm
experiencing now,
but I've been dealing with back pain for like 10 years and
it flares up and it's moderate lagging,
you know, kind of all the time,
but this was something totally different.
Like it just hit a whole new level of excruciating to where
it's like, it's not even like, oh,
I shouldn't go to the pool.
It's like, no, there's no way that I could do
anything physical today.
Hmm. That's a bummer.
Yeah.
And I can't even blame it on your past your inability
to do proper flip terms or something.
(both laughing)
Yeah, I know.
But this was meant to be like a coaching call where we're
gonna track the progress and like here's what you need to be
doing and all of that.
But like, I think what's instructive for anybody who's
listening or watching this is, like,
how do you roll with something like this?
How do you keep your head screwed on straight,
how do you stay positive?
And it just sucks when you've invested a bunch of time and
energy and you have a goal and then you have a setback like
this, and it's unclear what the next right step is.
And how do you remain enthusiastic about your fitness when
you're being told,
like you need to not do anything right now,
it's very dispiriting.
And as somebody like yourself,
who only feels good when they're in some kind of daily
movement practice to not do that feels like you're living
somebody else's life.
Yeah.
I mean, for me,
what I usually tell the athletes is this is a short window
in time and these events aren't going anywhere and we can
find adventures, but let's get you healthy first.
And let's work on those first steps
in order to kick out the other side,
to make the decisions we would wanna make in order
for you to still have the experience, the adventure,
that growth that you're looking for.
So that's the first part of it.
The second part of it is also understanding that, you know,
we can't force these things and sometimes the universe
for lack of a better description,
conspires against our best intentions and our willingness to
take action, because here's the thing, right?
We're taking action on the things that we said we would do,
and you feel knocked down when the action you're taking
is detrimental to what you envisioned,
which be your progress and who you want to be, right?
And so, but knowing that there's another side to it,
that on the other side of this adventures
will present themselves.
I will say this,
my greatest disappointments in athletics have always
presented opportunities on the other side that allowed me to
look back at the disappointments and say,
"Wow, had I not had that disappointment,
"I would've not been able to experience this."
And that has sustained me and many athletes over time
because the path, how we just sort of navigate that path,
presents an opportunity at some point where we all,
if we are in the right place mentally too can say,
"You know what? It actually worked out for the best."
Yeah, yeah.
It's good to hear that.
That's very reassuring, I appreciate that.
I think it's, you know, for me, it's disappointing,
but I'm in a very different place than I was in
like 2009 or 2010.
Like had we been in our like prep for Ultraman and something
like this happened, I would've been devastated.
Because I had so such high expectations
and so much of my life was invested in that, at that time.
But now it's like, well,
I'm doing this for the joy and the fun and the challenge and
to stay connected to my fitness.
And you know, if it's not gonna work out now,
like that sucks,
but I can live with it because I'm being nourished in my
life in other ways, it's just disappointing.
And also I have to check myself from self judgment.
Like, I'm somebody who, if I say, I'm gonna do this thing,
like, I want be the guy who does it.
And then if you're like, well, I'm gonna do this thing.
And then you're like, well, now I'm not gonna do this thing.
Like that doesn't feel in alignment with like the
kind of person that I want to be or how I wanna
perceive myself or how I want others to perceive me.
That was me last summer Tahoe, right.
I had trained, I'd done it.
And circumstances of being sick in that window
had me getting out after 45 minutes or an hour,
like come on.
And that's kind of like a first for you.
Yeah, yeah.
And, it's brutal,
but I know that lake is still there and I know deep down
inside, I will still do that.
I will follow through on my word.
It's not a question of if it's a question of when.
And so that is my anchor.
That's what I hold onto.
I will eventually follow through on the things that I said I
would to myself, right.
And to our own personal accountability, our word,
and you know what I mean by that,
like we just say something to ourselves and we put our
vested interests and our mind and our thoughts and our soul
behind it.
We are very connected to following through on that.
But again, it's not a question of if
that's the part we know, we know we will.
It's a question of when and, you know,
with the expectations around it, of how.
Of okay, I'm not expecting to win this,
or I'm not expecting to set the record of,
let's say crossing Tahoe.
It's a question of doing it.
And I will follow through on my word on that.
And similar to you just think 10 years ago, or 12 years ago
had something gone wrong prior to your Ultraman buildup.
You know,
we would've applied that fitness in some other realm
and you would've had a very...
Who you were meant to be and where you are today.
I think that path would've converged either way.
We're just caught up in the event itself because that's what
we're so laser focused on.
But I think over time,
you would've ended up with the same accomplishment
and the same insights and the same growth
and expressing truth of who you are anyways.
Yeah, I believe that.
I believe that, I guess the question on when becomes,
for me in a specific way, like, what does that mean?
Like, let's assume my back starts to loosen up
and it still hurts,
but it's not as bad as it was a couple days ago.
When is it appropriate to try to push it
and see what's going on there?
Like, I'm pretty good about knowing the difference
between just something you can ignore
versus something that is truly problematic.
Oh yeah.
That is gonna be made worse by training.
And that's a very kind of personal connection that you have.
But assuming I can get back in the water in the next couple
days, like what does that mean?
And what does that look like?
I guess I just have to play it day by day right now.
You do, but you can also start wrapping your mind around.
I need to only build once, in our background
for you and I as swimmers and just the experience of life,
how many times we've trained for something,
whether that's for Ultraman, whether that's for swimming,
whether that's for any endurance event.
So many of us are familiar with the old school way of you
build, then you come down,
you build even further and you just build up your confidence
and your ability closer and closer to set distance or event.
And then you come down taper one last time and you do it.
And you have this confidence that like I did, you know,
16,000 yards, I'll be fine doing 20, right.
Or people getting ready for a marathon.
Well, I need to run 22 to 23 miles just,
and then, you know, come down from that.
And that way I have that confidence in it,
but there's also the other way that you build
completely to that day.
And that is the day that you do your biggest swim, right?
(both laughing)
Yeah.
And so we'd use the time we have available,
once you're able to swim again and feel connected to your
stroke and your movements and so forth to sort of
mathematically, almost build back like, okay,
how are we gonna fit in some confidence,
building longer swims, get you to a point where you're like,
all right, I can see how I can navigate a path
and with my muscle memory and my experience to do this
just once and that's on event day.
Right.
And what are the mental coping strategies that you tell your
athletes when they suddenly get injured and are, you know,
spiraling outta control?
Well, I use that time for them to work
on the infrastructure around their training.
Could they be eating better?
Can they get more sleep?
Can they do things at work so that they lighten up their
load for when we do have the ability to train again,
can we take this time with kids and families that we're sort
of banking on time knowing that those days are coming where
we're gonna have some longer days and everybody is on board
sort of understanding like, all right, you know,
this is his window, or this is her window.
We need to get the work done.
But we had some amazing advancements in the infrastructure
and in our time together or weekends away until then, right.
Investing in everything else besides your training
and building up either goodwill or the infrastructure.
The infrastructure to me is sleep, and nutrition, and
hydration, and mindset.
So that you say, all right, everything that I'll need then
I am banking on now.
The difficult hours or the boring hours, or for many people
like on a trainer in a garage when after three hours,
their brain's going a little cuckoo that they're like,
well, you know what, two weeks ago,
I was dying to be able to do three hours in the garage.
Now I gotta flip that switch and really sort of take that
into a deeper level so that I have that available
when the difficult moments come up again.
Yeah.
Solid advice is always before I let you go,
you guys just did a big training camp up in Sonoma, right?
Yeah.
How did that go?
It looked beautiful.
It was amazing, and we had a lot of fun.
It was a really good infrastructure of a camp.
And there's a lot of ideas and things you can do up in
Sonoma because there's a 50 mile race,
literally on the shores of Lake Sonoma.
There's tons of great bike rides.
And of course there's tons of great open water,
swimming and paddling and so forth.
The challenge, as I would say more around
what different athletes,
when you put 12 athletes together,
what they perceive as ultra endurance
is not quite what I perceive as ultra endurance.
(both laughing)
So convincing them and having them stick with it
for three big full days is the challenge, right?
That's where they're expanding on
what they thought they were,
on who they knew themselves to be
and discovering this version
of themselves where it's like, I can't believe
I'm still capable of doing 100 mile bike ride,
after two huge days, I felt awful.
I couldn't sleep,
and look, I was still able to get on my bike.
And so that's the hardest work I would say.
It's not about the training.
It's about shifting people's attitudes
and mindset towards more.
Right, but how empowering you get through that
and you're like, I mean,
I've had those breakthroughs and you're like, wow,
that's something I never thought I would be able to do.
And it just raises the ceiling
on your own sense of personal capability.
Yeah, and it's an experience that I want
everybody to have.
Not even my athletes, when they just can see this version of
themselves, this potential being unleashed.
And then it expands in the other realms of their life, work,
and family, and personal life, and community
that they're capable of so much more than they thought
it's beautiful to see.
And so this is just a small little window to show them
what they can do, what potential truly is.
And unlocking that is awesome, it just makes my...
I come home from these weekends completely invigorated.
That's cool man, when's the next one?
It's gonna be a while, I'm too busy.
Yeah.
I'm off the Jesse's Driveway to Hell this week, so.
Oh, you're doing he thing in Connecticut
with the hill, you mean.
He has a new one.
It's in his driveway at his Rome, Georgia place.
And it's a...
So he's got a new one.
He just did a weekend there.
I was seeing on Instagram,
like he got a bunch of guys out in the middle of nowhere
with Chad Wright.
Yeah, and testing.
He was also there testing the driveway.
And so it's a half marathon on the driveway,
straight up a hill, like...
(both laughing)
So I'm not doing it.
Excellent man.
I will be there to support.
Gotcha.
Well say how to Jesse and it's always good to talk to you.
I appreciate the check-in.
I'll keep you posted, who knows what's gonna happen.
And for everybody who's watching and listening,
you could find Chris @aimpcoach on the internet
or ampcoaching.com.
And we'll talk to you again soon my friend.
All right, hopefully you're in the water again next time.
And we're talking yardage.
Hopefully fingers crossed, we'll see all.
Yeah, keep you posted.
Always appreciate your counsel.
Thanks so much man,
Of course.
All right, man.
Bye.
Talk to you soon.
(soft music)